why do you say that desire cannot be
taught desire for success is different
than desire I think
desire to be great to be an artist to be
outstanding at what you do is very
different than the desire for success
and I think it's look there are people
who are just inordinately ambitious
right out of the shoot they just are
um
but I don't think it can be taught I
think what you I've I've always said
this and I think it's true
I can't teach Talent we talked about I
can't teach desire but what I really
teach well I think is
a strategy for the senior working on
right now for the project that that's a
part of for your career and for your
life if I don't want to get two life
coachy about this but it's kind of all
the same it's understanding
that your innate talent and desire is
just there or it's not I mean I have run
across people
who are very talented and don't have the
fire in the belly to be successful they
don't care about it they're not it's
they're perfectly willing to be
just in the mix
I I taught a I taught the first time I
ever tried anything this was at the
Hawaii International Film Festival a
long time ago and it was uh
fantastic gig because you got to spent
two weeks in Hawaii
and I taught a week-long workshop
for actors and there were a number of
actors there who live there and and all
that
and there was an older gentleman
um who was auditing he wasn't part of
the actual workshop and he was we had
people who were auditing and all that
just to sort of
hang out and be and see it and observe
it and all that at the end of the week
he came up to me with some questions
and he said
um you know I was an actor
I said oh yeah and I said you were very
familiar looking so I probably have seen
you and and yeah he said I was I was an
actor in in did some TV and a little bit
of movies and
he was older and I guess had retired and
he said you know I said I just thought
if I can just make a living at this
he said and that's all I ever did was
just just make a living at it
and I took that to mean and he and he
this is what he meant that he never sets
his sights high enough he was just
satisfied being in the mix just
satisfied being on set just satisfied
getting that call that he got a call
back he wasn't he didn't aim high enough
and if you aim up here
you might get here but if you aim here
you're gonna get there you're going to
get so that desire I don't know I don't
know where it comes from I mean a lot of
it's cultural depends on what culture
you're from and and you know whether
it's
um a minority culture or you know like
in my case I'm Jewish and it was just
always imbued in us that you've got to
be you've got to be better than
everybody because you're going to be
judged harsher in a more harsh way and
all that so I don't know that was
you learn at your on your daddy's knee I
guess
what if we take the flip side and that
is someone who is maybe not that
talented but is incredibly ambitious
whether it's cultural or they want to
show those folks back in high school or
whatever it is
how do you reconcile that someone who
keeps trying and banging their head
against a wall but it's just not there
well
um
how do they reconcile that I don't know
I I do think that um
Talent is a commodity tell everybody at
the professional level is talented
enough to be in
you know the rookie or or 9-1-1 or some
of these kind of b-minus network shows
they don't mean to insult anybody but
you know they're not the same as the
streaming shows there's much higher
quality so they're talented enough and
there are people who are what I call
like mono talents they have like they do
one thing
but they do it really well and it's it's
commoditized
and they become a go-to person for that
one thing
and you've seen people we've all seen
people go oh it's that same guy he's
doing the same you know he's he's the
security guard I was talking into this
and whatever A lot of it is just is
I don't really know I mean there are
people
um who are who are
there's an actor I won't mention him
because I won't mention it but uh wildly
ambitious I mean I have never in my life
been around anybody
where every breath of every day was in
the furtherance of their Ambitions it
was breathtaking
and this person succeeded greatly
talented
absolutely talented but
um
I think that you know it leads to kind
of uh
not kind of it leads to kind of an
unbalanced life when you are that way
and I don't think people who are that
way can't really control that that's
just how they're wired I think a lot of
this comes down to
how you're wired I mean I interview
people frequently uh to be in our studio
and I don't take everybody because I
don't want to and I don't need to so I I
really I don't know any other way to do
it I just say hey let's let's meet or
not now it's kind of on Zoom like we
meet on Zoom
and tell me what you're after and let's
see if we're rowing the boat in the same
direction and if we're not you won't
hurt my feelings
so the people I have pardon me
in my circle of of students and
colleagues and clients are all people
I've curated let's say
and so I I get
consistently I'll say people will say
it's an incredible group of people just
a remarkable group I said yeah it is
because I take the time to get to know
them a little bit and not everybody gets
who wants in gets in exactly so
um I forget the original question what
was your original question about desire
being taught but I love what you're
saying here and that not everybody that
comes in to audit the class or be part
of your class is the fit
how can you tell somebody really wants
it
um
I don't know how I can describe that but
you the first thing I will do is
um I have I have two exercises I do with
new new students and sometimes I do it
when I'm meeting people to to be
involved in the studio
one is something that's standard and one
is something I made up and the one
that's standard is I'll say show me
something whether you want to do it live
or on Zoom or you've taped it show me
something you're really good at I want
to say something that you're really good
at that you think this shows everything
that I really want to show
and most actors have something like that
in their back pocket a piece they did in
a play or a speech in a movie or
something they did in the class that
they think this kills
so that's what you can do that's what
you can I want to see what you can do
now on the other hand I want to see who
you are so I said I want you to write
something
and a lot of actors kind of roll their
eyes they don't like to write but um
I said I want to know what you know
I want to know what you know what do you
know
I want to know what you know about how
you get up in the morning and how you
like your coffee and and traffic and
your dog and and start every sentence
but this is what I know I know that and
I said and don't edit it just write it
stream of Consciousness I don't need to
know anything you don't want anyone else
to know I don't need to know anybody's
deepest darkest Secrets this is not
therapy this is your world view I want
to see your world view and I want to see
what you can do what you can do and who
you are who you are always trumps the
world view in film and television
personal identity art form that's it's
it's maybe always been that way
but it's more that way now it's how else
do you explain
certain actors I've used I use it in my
in my TED Talk use Seth Rogen as an
example right I mean
I think he's great but he does that
he does he's the best Seth Rogen he
could possibly be and no one else does
that and his because he has a world view
because you know immediately when he
comes into
some sort of transaction in the scene
you know immediately I was going to
respond because his worldview is so
clear
most actors don't have that because
we're trained to be somebody else we're
trained to be
um
your effect you're applauded to be you
know oh I didn't even see you there I
didn't recognize you
that's not what film and TV is about and
that was kind of the the Genesis of my
deciding eventually that I was going to
try to teach was to sort of
try to teach to that perspective because
I didn't see anybody else doing that
and so when someone comes in and they do
the writing exercise of of this is what
I know
um I know I like my coffee with cinnamon
I know that I um like to wake up and
check Twitter you know if if they seem
reluctant
to do that exercise do you see that
maybe there's not a willingness yeah
sometimes or
when we were we're still we're back in
person though we were on Zoom for a
couple years as I'm sure you know and uh
when we were in person before it was
like first of all you're coming in you
don't know anybody in this class
you're speaking about how you see the
world around you in front of a room full
of strangers out loud
that's risky
it's a little risky that's why I say
don't I don't want to know anything you
don't want anyone else to know I don't
need to know no one needs to know that I
just need to know how you see the things
how you how you interact with the world
around you and so yes people will get
they're either like they pull back from
it or they or they're trying to be
clever and it's not really clever or
they're uh
they find themselves getting caught up
in it and getting emotional
because and I'll often say no did you
learn anything about yourself that you
didn't know before you did that and some
of them say yeah that was really
interesting because we know these things
but to actually write them out
and speak them
is different
and that's I mean that's the only time I
do that and it's It's Tricky it is
tricky and this there's a whole
um
in all of the training of artists
whether it's acting music
there is a teacher student relationship
that's tricky you know the the whole
Guru thing which is very prominent which
I really abhor uh so you have to be
super careful even more so today with
our world today you just have to be
super careful that you're not
um
leading them into territory they don't
want to go into and I make that's I make
that very clear and and knock on wood
I've never really had anything that was
like a train wreck with that exercise
and what about when
one thinks they know themselves but then
they are in a room of strangers with
something quite innocent revealing about
themselves nothing no deep dark secret
and the room shows them they're not who
they thought they were
does that happen that's not
um I don't think it's ever happened like
that I used to also do an exercise
though that might
play into that
um
idea
I would say
I've done this one for a long time
somebody would walk up on stage say
their name and uh I don't know I've
given a sentence like you know hi my
name is Michael Laskin I'm whatever give
them something to say and everybody
would have to instantly write down three
words
like what did you get from that
from that blink of an eye thing it's
that blink of an eye thing that is so
we have that in in in life I mean
somebody comes to my door to deliver
something or or a friend or a relative
we have an immediate human reaction to
that person it's the same thing on
screen it's exactly the same thing on
screen so when I started acting I didn't
under when I started acting on film and
television I didn't understand that at
all and I was not good
I I was not good initially I really
wasn't I mean I had to learn that it's a
different thing entirely
and that began my education toward what
I'm trying to teach now